[Music]
i always love
asking about the value of having a good
scene partner someone who supports your
work in addition to
delivering their work well yeah on their
own and
when it comes to game of thrones it
seems like that's of the utmost
importance for the scenes that you share
with lena i mean it's pretty much every
single
scene that you guys share together seems
incredibly demanding to me so
what was it like working together and
what were you two able to do for
each other to make those scenes i don't
know maybe maybe not like
miserably challenging or maybe that's
just when i'm perceiving them
i think the the key with lena and myself
was we immediately got on we're both
what we would call here birds
we're not like fluffy girly girls
um we got on immediately we really dig
each other
from the word go and i think that we
we just realized that it was very much a
bit of teamwork
on that and um which
she and i are friends still today and if
you think about how much
how little time rather that we actually
spent on that together
that makes me feel like they got the
chemistry right there
um and i was acutely aware of coming
into something where she had been
carving out
such a magnificent three-dimensional
character for five
seasons i i owed it to her
and to her detailed work
to come in and bolster that up
around her so um i'm just glad that it
was so well received and that she and i
are still
very silly friends